on Thursday night's American Idol  contestant Tristan shared how her  grandfather introduced her to country  music and that brought up memories for  Keith Urban  it was so touching my dad got me into  country music and he passed away in  December so I got a little emotional  watching that after the show I talked  with Keith about how he's remembering  his dad now after Tristan performed he  brought up your dad and said that her  talking about her grandpa reminded you  of her of your dad oh yeah the support  that she got from him and especially in  the realm of country music you know I  felt a real strong connection with that  I'm sure you must think about your dad  every day every day of course yeah but I  you know see him in our daughter's eyes  as well I'm immersed in my dad's or a  huge part of me of course I'm just  trying to you know be a good husband and  raise our kids right and you know do do  or do all the right things that he  taught me  you